France 8 personnes en haut qui était
suspecté d'avoir contracté ce nouveau
variance les autorités sanitaires le
nombre de contamination lui continue
d'augmenter avec près de 32000 nouveaux
cas ce weekend on va avoir plus de
précisions avec notre reporter tout de
suite Katia pique-nique
[Musique]
Katia bonjour alors le ministre de la
Santé a pris la parole hier concernant
ce nouveau variant Omicron est-ce qu'on
en sait plus ce matin
oui alors on en sait plus en tout cas il
a donné énormément d'informations sur
Omicron on n'en sais pas beaucoup non
plus en tout cas également sur la
vaccination l'heure de sa visite 162
l'assignation à Paris
vous avez appelé le nombre de
contamination hier qui ne cesse
d'augmenter alors pour commencer à
parler uniquement de la situation des
infections ovarian delta est bien la
campagne bat son plein pour tenté de
freiner la 5e vague ces deux derniers
jours plus de 710700 miles Français ont
reçu des injections de Raphaël qui
peuvent être effectuées dans une
pharmacie chez un médecin j'ai un
infirmier infirmière libérale un kiné ou
même une sage-femme 300 nouveau centre
de vaccination vont être ouvert à
préciser le ministre et 7 million de
Français en temps si reçu leur 2de
rappel le ministre a en outre assurer
que la France disposer de 25 à 30
million de dose de vaccin ARN messager
supplémentaire en stock et puis
concernant les Français qui ne souhaite
pas se faire ciné les Halles évidemment
en juin à le faire ils sont environ 6
million en ce moment est le ministre se
réjouit que 30.000 primo vacciné et bien
ce weekend donc son
autre inquiétude le vaccin au
micro-ondes vous en parler qui se répand
malgré les fermetures de vol qu'on
connaît et donc
suspects qu'il y ait peut-être 8 ans en
France en tout cas c'est une question
d'heure dit le ministre concernant ces
nouvelles contamination
problème avec ce virus comme vous le dis
pas forcément plus dangereux mais il y a
beaucoup de mutation sur cette nouvelle
forme en particulier sur si tu appelles
la protéine Spike la porte d'entrée du
virus dans nos cellules donc c'est
justement elle qui est ciblé par les
vaccins si le signifie qu'il faudra
peut-être les adeptes et faire de
nouvelles recherches alors peut-être
plus contagion tout cas pas forcément
plus dangereux mais évidemment cela
remets en question encore les questions
de vaccination avec les nouvelles
recherches pour tous les LED
merci beaucoup quelqu'un pour toutes ces
précisions à Katia pique-nique en direct
du ministère de la Santé ce matin